You know, I've been suspecting more and more
over the last few weeks that Donald Trump
may not realize that in the context of voting
in November.
Absentee ballots and mail in ballots are exactly
the same thing.
Now, Donald Trump hasn't specifically said
absentee is fine, but mailing is bad, or at
least he hadn't up until a few days ago.
But in his attacks against vote by mail and
his defenses of absentee voting, I got the
sense that Trump seems to think we're talking
about two totally different things.
We've now removed all doubt.
Donald Trump does think absentee ballots and
mail in ballots are two different things,
one of which is fine.
The other is totally subject to rampant fraud.
Now, remember that the context of this entire
anti vote by mail thing, it's related to coronavirus.
The idea is it may be too dangerous to go
out and have large crowds voting in November.
We're going to be in the middle of a pandemic.
In all likelihood, some states will be worse
off than others.
And we should allow anyone who wants to to
vote by mail by getting an absentee ballot
mail in ballot, absentee ballot.
In this context, it's the same thing.
Now, I want to issue one caveat, because I
know I'll get some trolls or maybe people
just genuinely misunderstanding in theory,
if there was just regular vote by mail, as
a matter of course, rather than a process
for voting by mail through absentee ballots,
there could be a difference between.
People are allowed to request an absentee
ballot vs. an entire state or country switches
to exclusively voting by mail as a matter
of course.
Those could be different things for November.
What we're talking about is just expanding
accent.
Absentee ballot access to anybody that wants
an absentee ballot.
So with that context, check out these quotes
from these tweets from Donald Trump where
it's clear he thinks these are two different
things.
He says, quote, Mail in ballot fraud found
in many elections.
People are just now seeing how bad, dishonest
and slow it is.
Election results could be delayed for months.
No more big election night answers, one percent
not even counted in 2016.
Ridiculous.
Just a formula for rigging an election.
Absentee ballots are fine because you have
to go through a precise process to get your
voting privilege.
Not so with Maylands rigged election, 20 percent
fraudulent ballots.
So Donald Trump clearly believes these are
two different things.
It sounds like he thinks an absentee ballot
is something you request, but a mail in is
you just I don't know.
You just get it somehow.
You don't have to go through some kind of
process.
So remember, for November in the United States,
what we're talking about is expanding vote
by mail, by allowing anybody who wants an
absentee ballot to get one.
Normally to get an absentee ballot in most
states, some states have open absentee ballot
request, normally to vote by absentee ballot.
You have to meet certain criteria.
Either you have a medical condition where
you can't go to the polls, you're living elsewhere
temporarily.
You're living out of the country.
You know, there there are sort of reasons.
You still go through the same application
process, though, if you expand absentee ballots
to say anybody can get an absentee ballot.
So there's sort of a few layers here.
One layer is you say anybody who wants an
absentee ballot is allowed to request one.
No matter what the reason, that would be one
one way, the next layer would be every registered
voter gets an absentee ballot application
automatically.
If they want to vote absentee, they have to
return that application.
In any case, this is all totally simple standard
stuff.
Now, again, in theory, you could have a 100
percent vote by mail system.
That is not merely an expansion of the absentee
ballot system that we have.
That's not what we're talking about for November.
We do not have that.
Nobody is talking about that for November.
For November.
We're talking about anybody who wants an absentee
ballot can request one.
In some states, hopefully every registered
voter will be sent an application.
It is not every person.
Trump wants to make you believe that.
You know, hundreds of thousands of undocumented
immigrants who are never registered to vote
because they can't vote in California are
going to be sent absentee ballot, no applications
or ballots will be sent to registered voters.
Now, I was thinking maybe the move here is
to placate Trump.
Imagine Democrats go to Trump and they say,
you know, sir, as he likes to say, you're
right.
Vote by mail is too dangerous.
You win.
Instead, we're going to just expand absentee
ballots.
We're not going to do vote by mail will expand
absentee.
Is he that uninformed that maybe he would
go for it?
Now, the reality is that Trump wants absentee
ballot voting or vote by mail for himself.
He wants it for his family.
He wants it for Caylee McKenny.
He wants it for people planning to vote for
him.
He does not want it to be easier or safer
to vote for people planning to vote for Joe
Biden at the core of it.
Yes, Trump is ignorant.
Yes, Trump seems to think there's a difference
between absentee ballots and mail in voting
in this particular election.
But ultimately, what this is really about
is Trump is losing on the issues.
His polling is in the garbage and he's looking
to win in other ways.
And suppressing turnout is a great way for
Donald Trump to try to win.
We can't allow it to happen.
We have to so overwhelmed the vote in November
that none of these garbage techniques are
going to work.
And that depends on every single person voting
and getting out the vote.
That's ultimately what this is going to come
down to.
We know they're going to try to suppress.
We know they're going to do everything they
can.
What October surprises can they put?
They're going to do it all.
They're going to throw everything at the wall
and see what sticks.
We just all have to vote.
That's that's the way.
If enough of us vote, it won't be enough.
We will overwhelm all of those tactics that
they are going to apply.
We're going to have more of this topic and
discussion on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page.
That's David Pakman show on Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there.
And for the latest garden updates, you should
see what's going on with my zucchini.
It's it's it's like nothing I've ever seen
before.
Doctors were shocked at how my garden has
faced zucchini grow.
Follow me on Instagram for those updates.